here's how you keep culture when in the
office is upset about something and i'm
on my way from connecticut into new york
to do a new business pitch potentially
worth five million dollars and i detour
and skip that pitch to go and talk out
with her that issue that's how you
maintain culture guys life's very simple
there's the things you wish you were
doing there's the things you're saying
that you're doing and then there's the
things that you actually do you do not
build culture by having a foosball table
or open seating you build culture by
actually talking to people one by one
and understanding what they care about
and what you will learn is some people
want money and some people want time
with their family and some people want
title and some people want creativity
and it is your job to know every single
one of those things about every single
person every single day because 23 year
old sally at 27 wants different [ __ ] 31
year old charlie at 34 wants different
[ __ ]